all right a trailer for the matrix for a
movie that was rumored like 10 years ago
and then it was like no this is really
happening and now we have a trailer i
i'm a sucker for good song choice and
blending the visuals as well as the
audio like you know the music and the
sound effects that go with the music
that's kind of it seems like a no [ __ ]
scenario like yeah of course that's what
trailers do but not all of them do in
fact it feels few and far between
between trailers that actually nail it i
feel like this trailer nailed it first
of all song choice white rabbit by
jefferson airplane not only is it one of
the greatest
swell songs of all time you know the
song that starts out very subtle and
then just climbs climbs climbs until the
climax of the song yeah white rabbit's
the song i'll reference when referencing
that also the the trial the court song
from chrono trigger but only that but
it's also thematically relevant to the
matrix but then it kicks off with this
very matrixy trailer music blended into
that song and it completely fits sound
effects like gunshots going with the
cadence of the beat i have watched this
trailer a dozen and a half times now
it's a killer trailer so i love the
audio visual blending aesthetic of it
all the way the music blends with the
sound effects and blends with the
visuals okay but what do we have for the
plot we don't really know which is
awesome i love that yeah the fact that
it's not like hey neo remember what
happened with you and agent smith all
those years ago well no they don't do
that it's just neo's here trinity's here
they're like have we met before so
you're like
is it
what is it i mean it's called the matrix
resurrection so is it dealing with
reincarnation in that respect you don't
know but neo's been having these visions
and so the doctor nph over here is like
i'm gonna do what doctors do i'm gonna
write you a prescription for that a blue
pill in fact he's tripping balls in his
mirror to the point where joe rogan's
about to have him on the podcast but
we've heard that the one is this
repeating anomaly in the matrix that's
just destined to happen so okay let's
say this is the next one again as we're
speculating this trailer gives you
enough to just speculate about i love
that about trailers let's say the robots
get wind of it's like all right we can
kill him and then he'll come back or we
can write him a prescription for blue
pills and just keep him subdued for as
long as we possibly can everything's
alternate realities now right
that's we're in the cinematic alternate
reality kick are we playing out the life
of that alternate neo in that alternate
decision that could have been made which
did get made here where that neo shook
hands with the architect took his blue
pill and went back to bed there is that
scene when he's in front of the mirror
and it looks like his face turns into
old agent smith's face which is that a
byproduct of how the matrix revolutions
ended it's like what are they like part
of one code now i do miss lawrence
fishburn though you know that's the
thing that i i you feel the loss here i
mean carry on moss is trinity in terms
of title in terms of her name but keanu
reeves carry on moss and lawrence
fishburne they're the trinity in concept
and execution who knows maybe this is so
far in the future he gets out of there
he's like i remember everything where's
morpheus i'm like
that was like 200 years ago
plot twist this movie's actually not a
sequel it's a prequel but in the end i
thought it was a really kick-ass trailer
i love the first matrix movie there was
a time where i was like i don't want the
matrix for because the first matrix i
saw someone describe the first matrix
and he said the first matrix was quite
naturally perfect it was a work of art
maybe he was actually technically
speaking he was talking about the first
matrix in that scene but the first
matrix movie is cinematic sci-fi
perfection and the sequels aren't as
good as the first movie and there was a
time i was like nope i just hate the
sequels but i've come to the point where
i can appreciate things about the
sequels like the merrell vinjian is a
great character he's incredible there
are things about the sequels i do enjoy
it's just they're not as they're not
what the first movie is i suppose that's
what the matrix four the matrix
resurrections rather is gonna run into
is it's not it's probably not gonna do
what the first matrix did in terms of
what it did cinematically to consciously
in terms of people's imaginations so now
i'm like yeah bring on a fourth matrix
movie worst case scenario it sucks and
the first one is still perfect but in
terms of trailer this was a pretty
kick-ass trailer alright so the matrix
resurrections trailer have you seen it
what did you think about whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you